مشاهدينا خلال اعدادنا الحلقه اليوم مننا
على دراسه لقيناها ملفته جدا الحقيقه
الدراسه اجرتها مجله بي ام سي بابليكالت
موضوعها تحليلي عن كيف الاطفال والمراهقين
بيشوفوا الحب والعلاقه والدراسه كان فيها
اصابع اتهام واضحه وصريحه موجهه لافلام
ديزني وغيرها من افلام الكرتون الكلاسيكيه
هذه الافلام من زمان متهمه بتميت صوره
الفتيات واظهارهم دائما ان سوره الاميرات
اللي بيهتموا بس باللبس والمظهر بيستنو
الامير يجي لهم ويعمل لهم كل شيء كده
وينقذهم انا اتهام جديد لكن الاتهام
الجديد اللي بتقولوا دراسه اليوم هو انه
هذه الافلام
الاطفال والمراهقين صوره غير حقيقيه عن
العلاقات والحب لا بل وحتى بتعطيهم صوره
سامه وبعيده كل البعد عن صوره العلاقه
الطبيعيه وكما يجب ان تكون الدراسه اعتمدت
حتى عالم مقابلات مع اطفال ومراهقين
ومختصين وتوصلت لانه هذه افلام بتصور
علاقات وحب خيالي او حرفيا مثل الافلام
فارسي ومو موجود في الحقيقه وبالتالي
بيعانوا بعدين لما يكبروا بينصدموا
بالواقع ودعه الدراسه كمان الى انه
المدارس في منهجها لازم تبدا تدرس مواد
ومهارات عن العلاقات وكيفيه بنائها
والحفاظ عليها وضمان انها تكون صحيه
وسليمه هتكون معنا من عمان دكتوره رشا
التميمي الطبيبه النفسيه اهلا بك معنا
الدكتوره رشا يعني من البدايه لما الواحد
بس انا اخصائيه مش طبيعي
للدراسه واقول لك انه يعني لما الواحد
يشوف الدراسه يقول طيب يعني ايش المشكله
انه يشوفوا قصص حب جميله بتنتهي بنهايات
جميله
الان يسعد مساكم جميعا بدايه
العام الخطوره بهذه المحتوى بهذا المحتوى
سواء كان من افلام ديزني او حتى من افلام
من شركات اخرى وصلنا على هاي لهذه الافلام
والمسلسلات لانه احنا الان في فتره الخمس
سنوات ست سنوات حتى ما بعد ذلك نحن الان
امام تشكيل شخصيه الطفل والطفله وما بعد
ذلك هي فاعل المراهقه تبنى بهذه المرحله
افكار
يعني افكار مخططات فكريه من تعاملات الفرد
مع اهله من تعاملات الفرد في مدرسته مما
يرى من وسائل الاعلام كما نعلم الان وسائل
الاعلام وتاثيره على الاطفال على
المراهقين مش زي زمان كانت زمان البرامج
الاطفال تفتح ساعه او ساعتين فقط على
ايامنا كانوا يحضروا يمارسوا حياتهم
الطبيعيه الان صار الاساس هو هذه الوسائل
التواصل او هذا المحتوى والاستثناء انه
يقوم الطفل مثلا يلعب
او مثلا يقوم بامر اخر فالخطوره انه تكوين
شخصيه الفرد هنا تبدا منها المرحله الان
ما ذكرتيه جميل ولكن في حال كان في همم
يعني حد او جزء او همم مستوى من المراقبه
ومن التفاعل مع من الاهل مع الطفل او همم
او اليافع في ماذا يرى من المحتوى يعني
اذا كان في تعليق دائم اذا كان فيه هناك
مراقبه طبعا مش مراقبه بشكل مزعجه ولكن
انه المحتوى يناقش يعني ما لا ياخذه على
على ايجابيات وسلبياته
بس معلش خليني اقاطعك يعني في هذه النقطه
يعني انا هتكون بتفرج مثلا على همم
سندريلا واقول لها حبيبتي ترى في الحياه
ما راح يجيك همم
بيبحث عنك بهذا الشكل وترى الحياه نكده
وحتتخانق وممكن يكون سيء ليه اعمل كده
لا انا ما بحكي لانه راح يكون سيء كمان
كمان لما احكي لها انه راح يكون سيء هون
انا بعطيها فكره ممكن انها تولد عندها ما
يسمى لاحقا بال في تشققات المعرفيه يعني
احنا ما بدنا ندخل به توقعات لا ايجابيه
زائد عن الحد النظاره الورديه اللي بنحكي
عنها ولا سلبيه زائده عن الحد احنا بدنا
نتعامل بشكل واقع يعني انه لما الطفل اللي
ذكرته اللي ذكرته عنها قصه سندريلا انه
بالحياه الواقعيه همم ما بيحدث دائما اصلا
عدد الامراء مش مش كثير كبير لهالدرجه انه
يكفي عدد البنات عندنا في المدينه او في
البلد وهذا ما بيحدث يعني دائما الا ب-
بشكل
العبره من القصه انه البنت تكون على
طبيعتها تكون رقيقه تكون طيبه فا احنا مش
ضروري انه نعطيها القصه كامله تاخذها كما
هي بالعكس انا هون يعني هاي فرصه انا نشجع
ال- ال- الاطفال ذكوره حتى لي عفرين انه
يولد عندهم التفكير النقدي انه انا ما اخذ
الشيء على علاته زمان كان مثلا المعلم
محمد الاطفال الاولاد بيصير عندهم فكره
خطا بسبب صوره سندريلا وسنووايت
بسبب تنامل بسبب هذا المحتوى ولكن عندما
يعني بتفاعل مع امور اجتماعيه مع تفاعلات
اجتماعيه بتعزز هذا التفكير النمطي او
القالب الاجتماعي
راح يطلعها من الهم اللي في ممكن او راح
ينقلها نقل نوعيه في حياتها اذا كانت
مستعد يوصل لها السعاده احنا هون بنزرع
افكار بصراحه مش منطقين ما بديش احكي صح
او غلط بس هي مش منطقيه مش واقعيه فعليا
هو هو بيجيء كمان هو بده حاجات ويريد
اشفاعها
مع هذا الكلام انه الطفل هذا صار سواء بنت
او ولد سيرين ان احنا نبقى نعطي له كثير
من الدربات همم يعني
هو في الصغر يعني الواحد في صغره بيعتقد
انه الدنيا كويسه انه ابوه وامه كويسين
وانه الحياه حلوه والحب حلو والاشياء دي
كلها مو ضروري نكسر له الافكار او نخليه
واقعي
الان ما بحكي لك هو هو المعيار انه هل راح
يتولد عندها هذه الفكره الفانتسيل الكثير
اللي هي خياليه جدا او لا حتى لا تصدم في
في الناس اللي راح تشوفهم تتعامل معهم
لاحقا حتى اني انا اعلمها انها تكون في
اللحظه انها تتعامل معه يعني يتم التعامل
معها تتعامل بناءا على اساس وما تتعامل
همم انه بصوره خياليه لانه انا بيجيني همم
ازواج وزوجات ال- بعد شهرين او ثلاثه من
الزواج
يعني متفاجئه مسروقه انه هذه هي الحياه
الزوجيه طيب انت شو تصورتي الحياه انا
فكرت انه احنا رح نطلع نروح على المطعم
ونلبس اواعي حلوين ونشوف ناس حلوين وما
توقعت انه كمل مسؤوليه لها هذا عليك فهون
انه لا مش منطلق سلبي لا من منطلق واقعي
انه انت مقبره على حياتها طبعا كل العمر
له خصوصيته طريقه الشرح طريقه المعلومات
المعطاه وقديش قديش بدك تعطيها معلومات
وكان بالتفصيل وطريقه التفصيل
لا انا ممكن احافظ على ايجابيه ولكن با
يعني واقعي منطقي اوكي النفسيه